I was asked to share my thoughts about
the Silicon Valley Bank situation I want
to convey that
um it's very uh indicative of what the
whole economy is like so there's its
particular situation and the FED coming
in and guaranteeing all depositors but
it's a common situation it exists
pervasively and what is it that I'm
talking about
that there has been a lot of creation of
debt
to make investments
um so for example Banks insurance
companies they borrow money at a certain
rate and then they go out and they make
investments and when those Investments
have lower returns go down in value as
stocks and bonds have gone down in value
or they don't have adequate yields
relative to the cost of funding those
assets you have everybody losing money
and that is a pervasive situation that
exists throughout the con the economy
the world economy the U.S economy in
other words the world is long so long
holding assets that their betting go up
and their leverage log meaning that they
have borrowed money to hold those
positions and so that set a circumstance
as we've been talking about has put the
Federal Reserve in this and our country
in a situation where
um there's um that it's very difficult
to create an interest rate that is high
enough to provide a real return in other
words a return after inflation that is
high enough to compensate you for
holding that asset to provide that
interest rate that's high enough at the
same time as not damaging those who have
borrowed that money that Balancing Act
is difficult and there's this big Supply
demand means that there's a need to
borrow a lot of money if you look ahead
and you say how much money needs to be
Borrowed by the Federal Reserve by by
the government
uh in order to deal with this situation
big deficits that means they have to
sell debt there's a supply demand
imbalance in other words those who want
to buy that debt what are they going to
buy it for they need to have a high
enough real return if they don't have a
high enough real return they can sell
the debt or their debt that they're
holding rather than buying that debt and
that creates a terrible imbalance and so
that imbalance is the nature of what's
going on so you and they're not marked
to Market these the a lot of these if
you mark to Market a lot of entities are
in financial difficulty